Travel is great but traveling can be a
struggle to help you navigate this kind
of traveling we pulled together a
mountain of data across seven different
categories and ranked nine major US
airlines from best to worst by basing
our stats on the percentage of flights
and passengers with problems we were
able to compare Airlines of all sizes
and that way we were able to truly say
which is the best airlines of 2019 and
which performed the worst Delta was the
most punctual airline in 2019
it's on-time rate including
international flights and regional
partners was eighty-three percent two
full percentage points ahead of Alaska
which was also significant since most
airlines had a tougher year last year in
terms of on-time arrivals in last place
frontier at 73% ever been stuck on the
tarmac
some times it probably feels like a
special circle in Dante's Inferno at
least Southwest had the lowest rate of
flight stuck on the tarmac for two hours
or more mishandled baggage is its own
frustrating discovery once you touch
down of all airlines Allegiant
mishandled bags least frequently while
American was the most likely to lose or
delay your checked luggage anyone who
lives with particularly rough winters or
overcrowded airports is no stranger to
extreme delays meaning a delay of 45
minutes or more so it's worth noting
that Alaska was the best in this
category with the lowest rate of extreme
delays
whereas JetBlue came in last place in
this category and of course the cause of
groans that echo through the terminals
of every airport the infuriating
canceled flight Delta made the top of
the list with the lowest rate of
canceled flights American was three
times more likely to cancel the flight
than Delta getting involuntary bump can
be gut-wrenching for passengers you have
a ticket you need to get somewhere and
the airline says sorry you have to go
much later
that means more gates sitting
it's no fun unless there's a Cinnabon
nearby once again Delta was best an
American was worst Delta only bumped
nine passengers in 12 months out of a
hundred and eighty six million people
American involuntary denied boarding to
more than 15,000 passengers over the
same period sometimes an experience can
be so rough it actually prompts a
passenger to file a formal complaint
with the Department of Transportation
this year spirit ended up with the
highest rate of passengers filing
complaints in South West at the lowest
rate thanks to all that data we were
able to rank each airline in each
category and we added up the rankings
for an overall performance evaluation
that showed us which airlines perform
the best in 2019 for travelers and the
winner is Delta Delta topped our survey
for the third year in a row
thanks much to its reliability it
canceled fewer than 1% of its flights
and it had the best on-time record even
though much of its operation is at busy
airports like Atlanta and New York JFK
Alaska and Southwest tied for second
place in the survey Alaska's worst area
was baggage handling Southwest and
canceled flights but overall those two
airlines provided very good service to
travelers in 2019 American was worst in
operational performance and has scored
at the bottom of our rankings in three
of the past five years
2019 was particularly tough since
American had a long contract battle with
mechanics which led to numerous delays
and cancellations surprise more
importantly if this knew something you'd
switch Airlines for let us know your
thoughts on our rankings in the comments
and we'll see you next year for the best
Airlines of 2020
you
[Music]